das ist gut für die us cameron diaz lag
mir auf der zunge ich den witz war
gehört cameron war ja ja stimmt ja dann
wobei mir ist es typisch dass die
minecraft spiele und den weg nicht mehr
zurückfinden zu meiner pace
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu dem
gewünschten battle zwischen max und mir
wir haben jetzt gedacht dass wir uns
hier ganz simpel einfach diesen bereich
abspecken auf dem server drauf und wir
haben jetzt 30 minuten zeit und gehen
jetzt in verschiedene richtungen treffen
uns danach wieder hier
wir wollen uns einfach die kur warte max
dadurch direkt los wir schreiben die
koordinaten in chat und zwar sind das
ixs -49 y scheißegal und z300 939 393
okay als dann würde ich sagen dass
vettel also das mittel besteht daraus
wir machen 30 minuten werden wir uns
jetzt auf das in zwei parts ist einmal
dieser part und eine nächste partie und
dann genau ich stell dir so ein timer
mit meinem handy
und genau dann in diesen 30 minuten
klingelt bei mir den wecker und dann
quasi dann geht's los
ihre lange zeit wären besser zusammen in
skype ja klar und deshalb ist das noch
ein bisschen lustiger und bringt aber
fein das dass wir ihr max perspektive
findet ihr auf kran crafter youtube.com
/ kernkraft hat löw noch nicht
losgelaufen umkreis ich bin aufgeregt
und das da könnt ihr am besten einfach
auf dem linken bildschirm oder irgendwie
so nebeneinander und perspektiven weil
es könnte auch sein dass wir uns
teilweise falsch zu sagen wie ich habe
gar keine diamanten und obwohl dann
schon 1000 diamant sachen hat also da am
besten noch nicht rum meckern oder so
und auch wenn dies beugt bei anderen und
schreibt zu hey komm mal kontrabass und
das bringt nichts weil wir das jetzt
alles am stück auf und schaut euch beide
videos an und dann würde ich sagen
countdown 3 2 1 es geht los die 30
minuten laufen
ich habe schönen dings hab schon hunger
balken verloren ich noch nicht das kommt
davon wenn du dinge zeitlos sprint ist
du bist schuld daran weil gespült wir
hätten uns eigentlich mit betten da
hinlegen können wir zwei so wenn jetzt
keine begrenzung gemacht weil wir
dachten jetzt einfach so kommen wir
haben halt ein bisschen wir sind halt
ein bisschen woanders gespannt aber das
wollten mitten im dschungel das war so
das tolle chance hat mir dann nicht so
bock drauf also wie derjenige der quasi
diamanten finden der eine direkt
gewonnen wegen dem schwert der forschung
zum battle gemacht max werten da
gewonnen
ich habe glaube ich
mehrmals gewonnen du warst ein bisschen
schlecht daran liegt auf jeden fall als
wenn ihr so gesehen habt von uns beiden
nicht holz nach es war megageil richtig
wir sind noch nicht gestorben oder so es
war richtig professionell und witzig und
geil ich wette gewonnen gegen max was
zur verwunderung von uns beiden er er
liebt einfach nur übel pferd überhaupt
nichts gewonnen und entschieden
und ja lecker lecker alles einfach bin
ich ja ich bin gerade dabei die ersten
die es abzubauen
ich baue mir gerade ein haus und so was
alles ich würde ich überlege mir danach
so ein schloss aus auszubauen
ja es gute investitionen habe ich auch
schon gedacht weil egal vielleicht
machen wir dann keinen dem schwert aber
braucht nicht umweg hat es ja auch
unnötig in den bettel dann wenn man
schloss haben kann
er wolle mir überlegen thema diskutieren
nicht als 4 und xbox mir ich weiß das
bist du platt getreten ist genauso wie
gta 5
was für ein thema könnten wir besprechen
ich weiß nicht wie ihr könnt man über
privatsphäre reden
da wollte ich mit den darüber reden aber
kann ich mit denen ja auch noch mal
drüber reden privatsphäre von youtube
ja genau also damit anzufangen auf
servern hat man diese privatsphäre
definitiv nicht mal kommt auf den server
draußen das kann selbst mag schon
bezeugen mit seinem semi dingsbums also
übrigens in den 30 minuten jetzt gerade
erst frieden dann das kann auch mag
schon bezeugen mit seinem mit seiner
semi dingsbums semi internetberühmtheit
pseudo das war doch wieso sollte
internetberühmtheit nennt man das ja
wenn uns hat mir so ein paar leute in
der branche hält kann doch nicht einfach
alle leute die im internet unterwegs
sind
selbst max wenn max auf servern geht
immer so auch krankhaft von crafter und
blablabla immer so dass es bei mir zum
beispiel sehr krass egal auf welchem
server ich als amerikanisches oder
deutsch irgendwie irgendwer kennt sich
halt immer und das ist holtwisch ist
crazy jemand denkt vielleicht so wenn
man wenn man das selbst nicht kennt so
ja das so mega cool wenn ein alle leute
erkennen aber glaubt uns es ist wirklich
nicht geil vielleicht
für moment oder erodierten vielleicht
aber dann fängt es an zu nerven also am
anfang
bei mir hat sich ist ja recht schnell
entwickeln deshalb konnte ich das
vielleicht auch so die ganze zeit dabei
von der entwicklung also am anfang als
ich noch nicht so ich sags mal so viele
abonnenten ich hab natürlich ball direkt
linie ist ein krieg explodiert wo ich
habe mich voll erschrockene alter
irgendwie hat mich erschrocken knecht
junge ich habe mich ja schon mal auf
einmal so laut war aber wohl spaß ich
bin gar fast gestorben vor angst davor
minecraft prägekraft wegen angst ist
nicht witzig german angst
der german angst der witzbold die
paranoia selter sie über die links auf
dauer also du wolltest irgendwas leben
du bist auf jeden fall ein sehr
professionelles play weil du bleibst
immer beim thema egal was da passiert
genau das zeichnet mich aus
also ich wollte sagen dass das ich ja
bei mir hat sich recht schnell entwickle
mit den arbeits deshalb kann ich mich
noch genau daran erinnern wie es war am
anfang habe ich mich mehr gefreut als
mich der erste erkannt hat seit ich
glaube ich 500 abos oder sowas und
dachte er ist erkennt mich jemand und
mittlerweile ist es durch kommen auf dem
server alle spam den chat das find ich
erstmal nicht schlimm wenn ich meine es
klar
cool wenn sich die leute freuen wenn sie
einen kleinen und sehr genauso freuen
wie mengen typen sehen würden den wegen
die übels feiern den treffer dann auf
den server da muss man ja auch mal sagen
das verstehen wir natürlich auch wenn
wir dann den eigenen server machen dann
kommen die leute drauf und liefen
einfach alles und was alles verheilt
verteilt haben die wahl ist auch
zupacken quartal nicht verteilt oder ich
wollte mich schon sein sonst vergessen
der servicekräfte punkten radio.net ja
ja das war halt schon ein bisschen
ärgerlich dann solche situation oder
genauso in der schule
ich laufe durch die schule und bei uns
gibt's halt zwei gebäude einmaleins für
die oberstufen aber für die unterstufe
wir sind halt manchmal auch bei der
unterstufe drin weil einfach uns
entwickelt sind nähe irgendwie für kunst
oder sport oder sowas solche fächer halt
für die man halt extra räume der halle
brauche oder bio oder keine ahnung und
da kommen dann einfach leute an daher
und das sind dann einfach solche leute
ich weiß gibt die einfach angst haben
oder keine haare hast aber didi rufen
wir das dann nur daher die gucken mich
quasi erst so ehrfürchtig an den dänen
vorbei so ganz normal und auf einmal
hinter mir dann kundschafter wer berät
was ich oben gucken sie wieder alle weg
dass sie zu voll die komischen irgendwie
das ist irgendwie weiß nicht was ich
verstehe nicht was in den köpfen von
denen los drin ist ist nicht cool
ich meine wenn ihr mich irgendwie in
köln geht oder wenn ich ihm unterwegs
sein könnte es gerne machen aber dann
auch so hingehen
conny regen autogramme irgendwie sowas
allerdings wenn man dann einfach weisen
nicht so total komisch dass man sie sich
sich so beobachtet fühlt und auch
irgendwie schule finde ich ist immer
noch so privater sollte man einen
eigentlich in ruhe lassen oder so es ist
ein kritisches und in die schule und
wenn man dann noch genervt wird der
schwer sind ungünstig ich habe damit
nicht so direkt die erfahrungen weil ja
noch ja schlimm wenn sie wäre in meiner
größe auf youtube aber ich weiß zum
beispiel von 1 ehre dass sie auch meinen
videos geguckt und die ist bei mir in
meiner rallye klasse was jack ahnt was
kann ich ja mal ne yo ich dachte das
wäre eine die so auch deine schule geht
und nichts entdeckt hat und dann so
meinte er geht auch auf meine schule
gehen so ach so ist echt zu einer rally
challenge max brod du ja max brod halt
nicht so lustig ein und lässt uns in die
kommentare bei mir geschrieben wie ich
doch die höchst max und lukas ist unser
name ist bei uns gut bei uns nicht sagt
luca ist ein fortschritt ich bin immer
noch dabei mit osbone tue ich baue mir
auch gerade an sni ich brauche keine
ahnung
46 die erst wenn ich das richtig sehe
alter ich habe 5000 oder 10.000 ich weiß
es nicht kann ich erzählen
ich habe ja meta genommen und einfach
ganz viele kräfte wettermaschine a
gemacht maschine niemals die macht noch
irgendwas netzwerk der welt machen
einfach irgendwas ja also privatsphäre
wenn ihr uns irgendwie sieht dann
sprecht uns ruhig an allerdings hat
jetzt nicht so unnötig viel nerven
so nach dem motto und luca und die
laufen weil wir wollen noch mal gesehen
uns nicht so oft und dann wollen wir
halt auch oft geschlechtsverkehr haben
und er auch dann in der öffentlichkeit
denn dann wären wir nicht gerne aber
gestellt
es hört uns an wenn ihr zu guckt ja aber
noch immer wir lieben euch natürlich
alle aber wenn ihr nervt dann sagen wir
das auch also ich sag zumindest immer
meine meinung wenn wir leute ein
bisschen nerven man erhält meine
minecraft 20 bisschen leise gestellt
bis man zu leiser ich mache ich gleich
mal laut wenn ich das richtig sehe werde
ich meinen tonspur auch ein bisschen
korrigieren müssen weil es sie ziemlich
leise aus da kannst du nachher in dem
ich alles machen so wo ich bin die ganze
zeit an ganz fieldings hat mühe vorbei
gelaufen
die krippe werden wir ein bisschen
hauptsache da ist der tausendste creeper
wer ehrlich ist nicht oft halte er fest
mit meinen links die welt ist keine
irgendwie die wir uns runter geladen das
ist eine zufällig generated wir machen
also bisschen ausgeschüttet ja wir
machen wird wir haben gedacht so ja
kommen damit mal wieder so bock drauf
sein battle zu einfach so ausgewählt
haben letztens wir sind auf meinem
server draufgegangen mit zu minecraft
genug zusammen
sein kumpel von uns und finden wenn du
das siehst wir lieben dich ja übel
nehmen von beiden seiten lieben dich in
beide löcher rein und dann habe ich
einfach ein bisschen gezögert und der
wahrheit mega schlecht und wir dann halt
mega des killer luxus ein nachricht
warte ich schaue ganz kurz wird viel
zeit denn noch haben in firma 23 minuten
noch vergeht wie schnell wir ziemlich
schnell ja also ich weiß ich habe bis
jetzt nur die als wir haben noch kein
holz ja ich auch erst mit liebe abgebaut
aber
mit liebe sagt sie ich bin jung ich
hasse es wenn gremmelin hoeneß du
gerätst es ab und es ist einfach immer
noch kreml darunter junge jetzt auch
fick dich ich bitte dich auf danke dir
sag mal ehrlich wissen wir dann wissen
wir sagen wie weit du bist ohne witz ich
hab noch fast gar nichts ich habe
wirklich noch nicht mal voller alten
rüsten
ich habe noch nichts egal was ich sage
du glaubst es wenig hilfe ich habe
wirklich noch fast nix also etwa ohne
scheiß okay sie bringen keine clowns
clown ist übrigens erlaubt das ist immer
bei battle so ich habe noch keine diaz
ich habe aber bislang erlaubt ist dann
möchte ich aber auch töten wenn du
kannst das darfst du nicht wo ich bin
luca ich noch meinen selbst beim server
kommt sagen die cloud ist nicht erlaubt
es uns auch doof wenn man seine anderen
land kommt dass du mir dabei zugucken
werde ich bekloppt deswegen ein bisschen
unnötig
wenn es erstmal so in den lava bist du
eigentlich in der höhle untergegangen
oder insassen weg gegraben
ich bin in der höhle unter gehört zu
welchem ihr sohn pikogramm
ok jetzt stoße ich nicht wirklich auf
erde
junge ich verstehe es nicht aufhöre 21
stößt man hier auf erde läuft du hast du
willst die auf die höhere untergraben
nee auf holz höhe ich hab sie konkret
tun der mit dem wie findet man diamanten
in verchen wieder groß geworden ist ist
so wenn wenn ihr das nicht kennt guckt
euch bitte an sich so mein erstes video
jungs richtig lustig denn du hast vor
noch einen anderen kanal der konkurrenz
ist richtig ab zu daisy hat mir letztens
einer erzählt ich habe da mal nix wenn
man es kann dich dich ja noch gar nicht
wieder
felix hat die felix aus erzählt welche
felix red pilz absurd klingt meint
designer der harvey so etwas erzählt
auch der hätte nicht schon so lang der
hat nicht der war einer der ersten
abonnenten auf konkrete beängstigend
bist doch krass ich find's cool das echt
krass seine nummer vier faktoren ihr
hergezaubert oder ich hab ich habe schon
so viel kohle und ich muss immer merk
wurde abbauen
wieso denn kohle dass milch ohne witz
alter baum krebs kohle ab das ist
minecraft da braucht man immer kohle ist
so eine junge immer wenn ich auf erde
treffe ich direkt andere richtung weil
ich kein bock eine schaufel zu machen
ich habe aber einfach noch keine diaz
ich hab eine schlucht gefunden
scheiße das ist gut für die kamera das
lag mir auf der zunge ich den witz war
gehört cameron war ja ja stimmt ja dann
wobei mir ist es so typisch dass die
minecraft spiele und den weg nicht mehr
zurückfinden zu meiner base h
kennst du das ist ja kenne ich war jetzt
gerade das nicht ich habe das problem
gerade auch nicht ich nehme es einfach
meine sachen alle mit
dann ist das in ordnung dann gehe ich da
runter zur schlucht obwohl es ihr
erfreulich hineingesehen hier einfach
ich finde einfach keine die als junge
hätte jedoch mit einem diaz macht ihr es
mit eisen rüstung
ich sitze hier mein leben lang neulich
hellwach leben retten
ich höre lava du hörst lava ja ich weiß
über das okay das lawa ich wäre was
reingefallen
als ob doch ist er jetzt viel mehr
geschrien
hier müssen doch jetzt auch irgendwo
jetzt ist echt was du kleine okay ich
gehe jetzt wieder nach oben ich muss
etwas holen damit ich diese nix sachen
abbauen darf als ob du hast junge
entweder hast du wirst niemals jetzt
gerade die us gefunden hat auf dem weg
nach oben zumindest wie kann ich werde
vielleicht die quote muss ich auch noch
dafür was ich machen möchte
du musst dir wohl eisen schmelzen die
kleine kicker jetzt unter druck steht
unter druck
hallo junge selbst wenn du denkst hast
wenn du dir echt noch keine rüstung
gemacht hast dann bist du bist todes es
geht vor allem bald los mit battle oder
eine viertelstunde aber noch 17 minuten
oder so locker sie was außerdem habe ich
drei 30 eisen oder somit das heißt man
mir dass meine richtung
vielleicht sollte ich mal was zu essen
machen dass wir eventuell auch noch ein
bisschen sinnvoll weil ich gerade verrät
haben hunger
aber ich habe oben gebratenes hähnchen
immer offen für alles gesorgt alter bist
du wäre es nicht ein annus ist jung
meine hände frieren ein herrlich werde
auch weil es auch im erfolg halte
handelsblatt pervers kalt machen das
fenster zu ja klar
ein händler die sind auch so voll so und
durchblutet wenig nämlich mit face
kammer partie auch machen können aber da
hätte der upload wieder so lange dauert
letztens habe ich ein video mit festival
an
hat fünf stunden gedauert und noch ein
bisschen 540 minuten gar keinen doch ich
hatte ich hatte sogar fleisch mit alter
wieso versetzt sind wir also sicher